hey everyone so today we're gonna do a
little vlogging action I got a new
vlogging camera here and I'm gonna try
it out this is a bit of an experiment
for me I'm also going to multitask and
get some meal prep done because you know
we only have so many hours in the day
but I want to talk today about my
vacation I just got home in September at
the end of September I don't if you guys
were following on Instagram but I was on
a beautiful tuscan vacation with my
family which was absolutely a dream and
I have I can't wait to go back you know
when you like don't really you don't
appreciate how amazing being away is
until you are home and back at work and
so that's how I'm feeling right now in
October but anyways that was amazing and
while I was away and posting all these
great photos of my food and the wine
that I was eating all that stuff people
often were asking me girl how do you eat
all those things on vacation and not
gain weight and not only that question
actually came up a lot and I started to
kind of think about you know how I would
have approached my holiday back when I
was struggling with disordered eating
and a rapport Exia and I absolutely had
those same fears I remember you know a
vacation for me
or just the thought of going on vacation
where I couldn't control every single
meal that was being made or how it was
gonna be prepared or anything like that
would send me into such anxiety just
thinking about it how like what I was
how is it I wasn't gonna manage how was
I going to kind of get around that to
the social aspect of eating and stay on
track stay on track and then what would
normally happen is I would almost kind
of just like give up basically at that
pursuit because I'd realize it is
impossible to control everything when
you are outside of your home and don't
have control over what you're eating or
what how it's being prepared
and I kind of swing in the opposite
direction and I would go and have a two
week binge so basically what my vacation
would look like was like eating pastries
all day long and massive tasting menus
and feeling so sick and bloated because
I would eat so much and I wouldn't dare
think of wasting a meal on something
light and nourishing that's
really what my body was craving like a
salad or a bowl of soup or a yogurt bowl
or some fruit or whatever because I knew
that that's what would be waiting for me
when I got home and I was like terrified
of that of going back to my kind of
restrict phase because I knew I'd have
to I'd have to pay for what I ate all
that time yeah there was a lot of guilt
and shame around that but if that feels
like you if that rings a bell to you
know that you're not alone and it
doesn't need to be that way I can
absolutely say that learning how to eat
intuitively was not something that
happened overnight that's that's for
sure I'm not going to pretend like it
was just like an easy easy it took a
little easy overnight course and all was
good and I could go and eat drink and be
merry
however after years of working at this
my relationship with food has completely
changed and the way I view and approach
of vacation and eating on vacation has
completely changed so I can go and I can
eat and drink and be merry and I don't
need to feel like I need to come home
and restrict and I actually find I was
thinking about this I actually find that
if ever I feel like I'm teetering into
kind of my regimented mentality I find
that kind of going on vacation is a
really great way to break that cycle and
I realize I am privileged to be able to
go on vacation and it doesn't need to be
a vacation it really could just be like
we need to break the routine whatever
that looks like however you need to make
that happen sometimes you just need to
get out of the routine to see that it's
not working for you and so switching
things up on a little bit of vacation is
kind of a really good way to do that so
let's talk about basically how I was
eating while I was away first of all
let's start at the beginning the day so
at the beginning of my of my holiday I
would wake up early before the baby and
my husband and
I would usually kind of like answer some
emails maybe I've had my coffee I
wouldn't be hungry because I was all
like jet-lagged and my my body was all
over the place and even though you know
for me you know you've seen my wedding
today I am a breakfast person I could
not do intermittent fasting so I'm not
one to wait till noon to have my first
meal so that was definitely an aperture
for me but I just genuinely was not
hungry until later on in the day so what
I found was once my son got caught up
and he was having breakfast I really
liked to eat with my son and make sure
that he has that kind of modeling you
eat so much better and for the parents
that are at home with picky eaters make
sure you're eating with your kids that I
really do think believe that that's
super important but I would have like a
small little snack with him so maybe a
piece of toast with some peanut butter
or almond butter and some fruit we are
saying an air B&B so we could do some of
that we could have make our own meals
and then you know I of course would have
my coffee very important side note on
the coffee's the lattes I'd have a soy
latte that's they don't have I usually
have almond milk here but they don't
have like almond milk there and honestly
my my order would be complex enough so
it was always soy milk while I was in
Italy and the coffee the lattes in Italy
are so small like I'm not joking like
three sips sometimes I'd be like that
there is no like Grande venti there's no
sizes they don't they look like look at
you like you're crazy if you order
something like that and I realize it's
because you know in Italy they eat or
they drink coffee partially as a social
thing but just to be sipped and savored
before they head off to work or whatever
whereas in America I feel like we drink
coffee and a lot of beverages in general
kind of as a way to like keep our mouths
busy and I found you know at first I was
like oh this is not gonna be enough I
found that I kind of really appreciated
some of the smaller portions because it
it really helped me kind of check where
you know when I was actually not really
enjoying anymore sometimes I sign now
after I got home from Italy that I drink
my grande latte and halfway through I'm
like I'm not even really enjoying this
anymore but
still drinking it because it's in my
hand so this was a really great way for
me to eliminate waste and also to kind
of get back in tune with what my body
actually wants and craves and needs
versus what I'm just drinking at a habit
because that's my order that's my
Starbucks or you know anyway so back
onto my day so after you know that we
would start our day and we would do so
much we would walk a lot like a lot a
lot a lot of walking to the point that
my legs were really tired that's what
you do and you're a tourist right you're
you want to explore you want to see it
all you don't want to just like to sit
back and hang out all day as a result
you know I sometimes would let myself
get more hungry than I normally would so
if I was thinking about this on the
Hunger scale at home and maybe would
start to have a snack around a 3 or 4 on
the hunger scale whereas there sometimes
by the time I'd I stop and sit down for
a meal I'd be ravenous I'd be a 1 or 2
and as a result of course I would
probably eat more a larger meal than
what I would normally eat as you know at
home I would eat until I was like an ion
the fullness scale versus like a 7 maybe
an 8 at home the key here however is
that I didn't punish myself I didn't
feel guilty about it
I didn't shame myself over it I didn't
say oh my god I'm so full I'm not gonna
eat anything for the rest day or now
I've gotta like go and find a gym and
exercise etc I didn't think about it I
just let my body be my guide and maybe
the rest of the day you know by that by
dinnertime I would probably again be so
hungry because I would be touring about
and doing things so I was really just
responding to my body's needs and I
wasn't going to let my kind of
preconceived notions about like what my
normal kind of eating would be at home
get in my way of like listening to my
body's needs in that moment and I think
that was that was like really important
for me because of course like I think a
lot of people who get into doing kind of
mindful eating or intuitive eating they
think about the hunger scale and I
really only use it sometimes because I
think we can also get obsessive about
that
and they think oh my gosh I'm doing
intuitive eating wrong or I'm failing at
it
you can't do intuitive eating wrong and
that's the amazing thing about it and so
I think this was a really great way to
remind myself that that it's ok if I eat
like past fullness once or twice or
whatever it's it's my body will make up
for it because it's incredibly
intelligent ok so then what happened
after that so then we go to dinner and
I'd always have wine because I was in
Italy and I pretty much always have
dessert because I love gelato and this
is the amazing thing about intuitive
eating there were days folks when I
didn't even finish my gelato because I
knew tomorrow was another day of
delicious eats as I could tour and I
could have gelato then if I wanted and
and that's a really like empowering
realization to make it's like this is
not the last time I'm gonna have
something delicious tomorrow is another
delicious day tomorrow is another
delicious day you know write that on
your mirror every single day and just
remember it because we don't need to
limit ourselves to just like these
little snippets of happiness through
food and through all of that you know
even though I was eating like I'm a
queen I think there was only one night
that I can remember that I went to bed
feeling like uncomfortably full like
stuffed where I like definitely like
overshot what you know my my nutritional
needs for the day and that was because
we were having dinner at NASA MOBA
Terra's restaurant if you don't know who
that is and are you even a foodie no I'm
just kidding I'm not a food snob but I
am a a big-time foodie and so Google
that he's his restaurants the number one
restaurant the world we were lucky
enough to have dinner there and got to
meet him and hang out with them and of
course it's a multi-course tasting menu
these are iconic dishes and I was so
excited I was looking forward to this
all year long literally so of course I
was going to eat everything and the wine
was a flow and they just didn't stop
pouring wine so not surprisingly the
next morning I was feeling it because I
don't really drink that much so yeah I
was feeling pretty sick but I wasn't
like I woke up the next morning and I
was gonna punish myself and say okay
well I ate so much and I feel like so
guilty about it I'm not going to eat
today
I did not have that condition in fact
Massimo also prepared this like amazing
his chef stead it's amazing gorgeous
spread for breakfast and I also want to
take in that and I was genuinely hungry
at that point I ate what I felt was you
know nourishing my body well and I moved
on and I think probably because I just
didn't feel up for another big heavy
meal that night we had like a lighter
dinner and that was perfectly okay that
was that was all that needed to happen I
didn't need to overthink it I didn't
need to punish myself in the days after
I didn't need to detox I didn't need to
find green juice I just needed to like
move on next day whatever what do I need
for this I'm doing some instapass I'm
just a newbie with the in spots so bear
with me folks one sec okay so you you're
catching up with me here so basically
where we're at is Massimo Botero ate a
lot whatever by the second half of my
trip I started to really kind of notice
and make some adjustments that you know
felt really good to me because we were
getting into a bit of a routine and so I
was trying to find ways like without
really even thinking about it it's kind
of like unconsciously finding ways to
eat in ways that really made me feel my
best again and so I definitely started
to crave vegetables like not in a oh my
god I ate so much pasta and wine and
gelato and now I need to eat salad only
but in like a legitimate primal way like
I needed vegetables I wake up and I'd be
like breakfast salad can we have salad
for breakfast we're gonna get salad for
breakfast and it's not like I had no
vegetables in Italy like they have
vegetables in Italy but they just didn't
like to serve a whole lot of fresh
vegetables because as you know when
you're eating in like a restaurant you
know it's never you're never gonna get
as many vegetables as you probably would
make yourself at home that's just that's
just my experience in in most
restaurants so I was really craving
craving a good veg and I think that's
like largely because a I wanted that
fiber and B I want the hydration and
that also is like really good for
regularity and things were feeling a
little slow by the end of my trip there
and
that's probably why so I was going for
straight for the veg that's for sure
they also started to pack snacks for
myself because that way I you know I'd
have to plan ahead like you know I knew
I'd be out museum you know viewing or
whatever for a few hours and I didn't
want to let myself get so ravenous that
by the time I sat down for breakfast or
in French whatever that I was just like
mmm give me all that bread cuz that
would happen and I think we like the
bread in Italy
don't shoot me folks I just didn't think
it was very good so I I never wanted to
eat it unless I was starving basically
cuz it just didn't taste very good to me
so I didn't want to get myself starving
so it packed snacks get both for myself
and baby II you know I think as parents
we always think that our kid and I was
always packing ham snacks but I was like
why don't we just pack some snacks for
me to like that would make sense so I
started to do that that also really
helped me sorry had to be interrupted I
got someone at the door someone on the
phone baby coming in gotta get the milk
ready all the things anyways back to my
story so what I wanted to say was that
this wasn't as a way to like undo undo
the damage of you know eating a lot in
the earlier parts of my holiday that
hasn't had nothing to do with it if
simply my way of incorporating what we
call gentle nutrition and gentle
nutrition really comes from learning and
paying attention to our body and and
learning what it needs to feel its best
ultimately and what I was meeting was
some more vegetables in my life I just
was have this like craving for that and
that makes like total sense so by the
second half of the trip most the time I
breakfast and lunch has had more you
know salads I was like actively seeking
out places where I could get a salad I
was having you know fruit yogurt and I
was also like drinking a little bit less
you know I'm not a drinker thing to
recover in general but I was in Italy
and so Solis is tempting but I was
finding that having
more than like one full glass of wine a
night was impacting my sleep and it was
interfering with my ability to get like
a good night's sleep and as you might
know for me talking about it earlier I
am a bad sleeper I am like I am an
insomniac and I'm gonna talk a little
bit about my journey on that if you guys
are interested so if that's Lyman your
insta didn't leave me a comment below
and I will follow that up with a video I
am adding a lot to this pot so I hope
this is gonna work so let's talk about
of course what probably a lot of you
guys are wondering and that is girl what
happened to your body and your weight as
a result of this holiday here's the
amazing thing like it really didn't
change and it didn't change despite the
fact that I was my eating was
drastically different than your normal
my exercise regime was very different I
really didn't have access to a gym for
till you know most of my holiday and it
stayed the same for a few reasons that I
that I'm aware of at least one is
because I was probably eating within my
needs
give or take for most of the holiday
even though I wasn't planning or
prepping or counting anything be is the
fact that like I've already talked about
this and in on my other videos when I
talk about set point theory but I really
truly believe that our body kind of
wants to be a specific weight or or
weight range and it'll kind of fight to
maintain that weight give or take
depending on what you do as long as you
are listening to your body and not like
consistently eating beyond what it's
telling you to eat or you know or under
what it's telling you to eat I should
also mention and see is the fact that I
wasn't previously restricting or
currently restricting my intake when I
was at home in any kind of way that
would make me or encouraged me to binge
out of control once I got on vacation
and I was outside the the kind of
comfort of my my regime at home so
there's really so much power information
and I think we often forget about that
and one of these kind of food driven
holidays like what I just described is a
great way a reminder of how smart our
body really truly is if we just give
give it the opportunity to tell us what
it means and I want to reiterate here
that I recognize that this feels like
something so far away from what you
experienced first some of you guys who
are watching at home and and I and I
don't want to diminish the struggle that
can come along with trying to learn how
to eat intuitively it's not just
something I figured out overnight this
is something I'm actively having to work
on even today but I want to I'm hoping
that this story is a bit inspiring so
that those of you who do approach a
holiday with anxiety which really kind
of defeats the purpose of a holiday
right there is hope there is an
opportunity for you to go on vacation
and not have to come home to not only
work and not a vacation but also the
anxiety of undoing the damage that you
did well away so bottom line I hope this
was interesting helpful inspiring I hope
this kind of gives you an idea of what
intuitive eating looks like in real life
and also a gentle nutrition looks like
in real life which we'll be talking
about as we go through the intuitive
eating series but I also really want to
reiterate here that a intuitive eating
is not something that I just picked up
overnight I want to make sure that you
guys know that I don't I don't want to
diminish the struggle that is learning
how to improve your relationship with
food when we when we've been so
engrossed in dye culture for so long and
I also want to really reiterate that I'm
hoping that my story brings to light the
idea that intuitive eating is not just
another set of rules there is no bar to
measure against to figure out like
whether we're doing it right or wrong
and intuitive eaters they eat beyond
fullness sometimes they let themselves
get ravenous sometimes the key is to not
judge ourselves and shame ourselves for
those experiences but rather to learn
from what our body is telling us and
helped that guide us in future eating
scenarios and situations and for me that
those lessons are invaluable they're so
amazing when we're actually tuning into
what a body is saying so guys I hope
that this video was fun and enlightening
I'm gonna finish up some meal prep here
if you like this style of video of me
kind of just talking or casually please
leave me comments below if you didn't I
know I'm still kind of learning this
vlogging situation so give me give me a
little bit of time to figure out this
camera I just wanted to jump in I am not
good at reading instructions so
hopefully it wasn't too terrible but I
hope you guys enjoy and have a fantastic
day don't forget to subscribe
oh I got a check on those carrots leave
me comments like this video I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]